well I think the results show a very
clear message which is people are deeply
disillusioned with the European Union
with the way that it's working with a
way that it's working for Britain and
they won't change the challenge is now
for my party to demonstrate that we have
the plan to deliver that change to
renegotiate Britain's place in Europe to
get a better deal for Britain to change
Europe and then to put the choice to the
British people in it enact referendum
before the end of 2017 that is what
we'll do and the real test for that plan
will come at the next general election
but I think the results show a very
clear message which is people are deeply
disillusioned with the European Union
with the way that it's working with a
way that it's working for Britain and
they won't change the challenge is now
for my party to demonstrate that we have
the plan to deliver that change to
renegotiate Britain's place in Europe to
get a better deal for Britain to change
Europe and then to put the choice to the
British people in it enact referendum
before the end of 2017
that is what we'll do and the real test
for that plan will come at the next
general election there are people saying
though that people voting for UK aren't
necessarily just interested in Europe
and that this is a kicking of the major
parties and that perhaps you are
completely out of touch on the issues
that people really care about but people
use elections like this to send messages
to the government and the message on
Europe I absolutely receive and
understand which is people want change
in Europe of course after a long and
difficult recession people do have other
things that frustrated about they want
to see more jobs they want to see higher
living standards they want to see us
complete our long-term economic plan and
I see that as a demand for us to deliver
and we've got to demonstrate that
tackling immigration reform will fair
get getting Britain's place right in
Europe all of these things are part of
our long-term economic plan that has
seen an increase in the number of people
in work taxes cut the deficit down but
there's a lot more to do now I believe
we can win the next election outright
and we should put in front of people our
message which is let's complete the long
term economic plan that is turning this
country around so we can win that
election we're gonna have to work harder
we're gonna have to do more we're gonna
have to convince more people and that is
what I'll be spending my time doing this
next 350 days
I believe we can win the next election
outright and we should put in front of
people our message which is let's
complete the long term economic plan
that is turning this country around so
we can win that election we're going to
have to work harder we're gonna have to
do more we're gonna have to convince
more people and that is what I'll be
spending my time doing this next 350
days okay and just one question about a
Nick Clegg he's looking pretty
vulnerable he is your Deputy Prime
Minister where does this leave the
coalition especially if he goes what the
coalition is a strong government that is
delivering for Britain particularly in
terms of turning around our economy
getting people back to work cutting
their taxes that work will continue
people will should be a no doubt we have
a strong and determined government with
a very clear plan and that plan
continues I'm very clear we have a
strong coalition government that is
effectively changing our country putting
people back to work cutting people's
taxes getting the deficit down we have a
very clear plan and my job as Prime
Minister is to stick to and deliver that
plan and that's what I'm going to be
working flat out doing over the next 350
days